around 1:00 1/8 American women will
develop breast cancer in their lifetime
Texas doctors performed breast cancer
surgery yesterday on 50 year-old Sonya
Johnson she broadcast her surgery live
on the hospital's Facebook page to raise
awareness in preparation for today's
surgery she has completed chemotherapy
to create shrinkage of the tumor to
allow dr. DePasquale the opportunity to
surgically remove the area from the
breast and do a check and evaluation of
the lymph nodes so that is currently
what we're seeing and observing Wow only
on CBS this morning Sonya and her
surgeon dr. Alison D Pasquale join us
live from Dallas good morning to you
both you both look great Sonya
especially you how are you feeling I'm
okay I'm just a little sore
I'm just working through it yeah surgery
went well
yeah I can imagine what we're happy to
hear that it went well and you woke up
this morning to join us so early 45,000
people watched you live on Facebook as
you underwent this operation what made
you decide to do it live it's such a
personal move and such a personal
surgery obviously for me it wasn't
really a question it was how can I pay
back so this to me it was an opportunity
to pay it forward to hopefully to reach
someone to let them know that this is a
journey but you have to be able to take
the first step to get tested and even
though it's scary and we know we've met
people along the way we lost people
along this journey it's doable if you
get tested early well it certainly does
send a powerful message Sonya I really I
marvel and I applaud you for doing this
doctor I want to this question is for
you have you ever done anything like
this before I know you've done the
surgery but have you ever done anything
live like this and were you worried
about if there were complications I
would think TV cameras if you're not
used to it are cameras
would make you nervous well no I've
never done this before but this was
something that I was willing to do two
ways away raise awareness for breast
cancer because social media is so
powerful we took extra precautions but I
operated just like I do every day
you know we focused on the patient the
main deal was getting Sonja out of that
surgery cancer-free did you have any
complications absolutely none good and
doctor when you say you want to raise
awareness exactly what do you want
people to know what do you want people
to be more aware about I want people to
see this operation and say oh wait I
guess I haven't got my mammogram in a
couple years and go and get their
mammogram just getting that mammogram is
early detection and can help save lives
Alison it's such a good point because
October is Breast Cancer Awareness Month
it's the reason I went and got my
mammogram this month it does help to
remind us we all need to remind and help
one another let me ask you this though
how often should a woman get a mammogram
women should start at age 44
average-risk meaning that if you don't
have a family history of breast cancer
or any other high-risk features and
every year they should get a mammogram
now if you have a family member a
first-degree family member who has had
breast cancer you go ten years prior to
that to start your imaging and doctor
you also recommend them for men as well
well men should get mammograms if they
have a problem if there's any sort of
changes in their breast tissue they
should bring this to the attention of
their physician and definitely undergo
diagnostic imaging Sonya you said you
were doing this too to start a
sisterhood to join the sisterhood of
survivors what is your message to these
other survivors out there my message is
you this is doable
get your get the testing first and it's
not that it's never too late it's never
too late to get it to get the testing
it's never too late to start I just
wanted to let people know that you don't
necessarily need to have any double
mastectomy or mastectomy there are
options there are more options
now they were I would say 20 years ago
mm-hmm
if you just take that first step and
just join the sisterhood I know that
this is a scary moment yeah a lot of
people but to just join it you might
your friend or your co-workers or your
mother or sister just do it to join it
you'll learn a lot along the way and you
like saying that you had cancer where
before you said I have cancer is that
true this is so true though I told
everyone that I have cancer
yeah now that I've had the surgery right
now I say that I had cancer yeah that
makes it different we are praying that
it stays that way as we write Sonja
Johnson may it stay in the past tense
thank you for bringing the sisterhood to
us this morning and dr. Allison
DiPasquale
thank you also